bien alors 73 ont fait toute votre vie
là ouais on est en 73
on n'est pas rendu ah ben c'est plus
long que la vie de dhr et marne et 1
vous prenez prétexte de la naissance de
votre fils pour dire je vais m'occuper
de lui c'est une bonne excuse pour
arrêter la scène quoi en fait je n'ai
fait ni l'un ni l'autre
c'est plutôt vous dis papa c'est plutôt
françoise qui s'est occupé de thomas oui
alors au cinéma au cinéma vous êtes
génial tout de suite premier fils
sébastien et puis ensuite pialat revoir
y avait eu d'autres mais je cite pialat
à van gogh parce que ça a été quand même
un événement vous dit en parlant de
pialat pour justement on en revient à ce
point il est urgent pour le vexer faut
le flat et voilà et alors il ya un truc
très sympa dans ce film c'est qu'à un
moment vous il avait écrit vous êtes
avec mademoiselle gâcher la fille du
docteur gachet dans la voiture non
languedoc et à un moment il y avait cinq
pages de texte et c'est pas que je n'ai
pas voulu les apprendre c'est que vous
avez réduit
j'ai transformé les cinq pages de texte
en un regard et c'est parfait ni anti
sûrement mais non je crois pas c'est par
l'allant non mais c'est vrai que j'étais
pas très convaincu de ses 5
j'ai dit il faut connaître le texte pour
se permettre de ne pas le dire je vais
bien alors vous êtes tourné aussi avec
godard vous dites c'est comme un petit
mais c'est lui qui paye et puis alors le
pire c'est spielberg alors ça c'est
incroyable match si j'avoue là je vous
comprends pas un jour cévennes philbert
demande à jack dit je voudrais pouvoir
c'est ça c'était pourquoi le privé c'est
indiana jones
oui je crois qu'il voulait que vous
soyez indiana jones ne sais pas mais
jusque là où je parle très mal l'anglais
donc la spielberg rencontre dutronc et
lui dit j'aimerais que vous jouiez
indiana jones et je vous ai dit beaucoup
de conneries parents des jeunes est
quand même non sûrement parce qu'il n'a
jamais rappelé qua non bonsoir jean
marie messier mesdames messieurs peut
l'applaudir
et puis alors après bon ben vous
rencontrent alors françoise hardy est
bon et bien souvent ici on sait à peu
près comment ça se passe chez vous donc
je vais vous poser beaucoup de questions
parce que l'on s'est tous ont parlé tout
à l'heure de l'amour fusionnel dresse
qu'il faut être comme ça toujours collés
l'un sur l'autre et se marcher sur les
pieds dans la salle de bains ou est-ce
qu'il faut prendre un peu de distance
pour conserver du mystère du fantasme
ans jacques puis l'a résolu le problème
une fois pour toutes un ils vivent pas
un état chacun sait ça voilà et ça dure
parce que tous ces coupes du showbiz ils
ont tous divorcés sauf le vôtre c'est
vrai regardez johnny et si et quand on
vous dit quand on vous dit ça fait 30
ans et vivait avec françoise hardy vous
dites on vous dit ça fait trente ans de
vie commune et vous répondez 30 ans de
vie peu commune
mais ce n'est pas un banquet c'est la
vie quand on vous parle d'elle selon moi
je vais demander d'ailleurs c'est moi
qui lui ai demandé quel don de la nature
voudriez avoir vous avez dit j'ai déjà
le doigt vers le pousse vers la queue
verte et je suis mariée qu'une belle
plante sûrs alors il ya un truc on n'a
peut-être pas être tout le temps
d'accord c'est i muvrini vous savez
qu'ici quand quelqu'un par le trop quand
quelqu'un parle trop il les mosaïques
est et on lui diffuse un petit morceau
d'imovie ni et vous ces volatiles
mauvais ni gris
oui l'effet que ça nous fait en
métropole
c'est marrant hein c'est bien oui
m'ouvrit ni vous a plutôt un mec qui va
leur en vacances ensemble qui passait
bien non je n'ai encore ça cet été
malgré une moue vridi un gp info n'est
évidemment avec une fausse barbe et une
perruque mais les signes et gildas sur
les bons alors votre maison en corse ça
va vous êtes toujours là bas c'est
tranquille moche à vos potes là oui
c'est vrai que vous parlez au chat oui
il vous fait quand tu vois quelqu'un il
parle de chaque camp fait quelqu'un qui
arrive dans le chemin il fait comme ça
comme avec son portable pour faire
croire qu'ils parlaient alors je vous ai
demandé à l'époque comment vous avez
fait pour vous faire accepter par les
corps si vous avez répondu rien
justement la situation politique en
corse vous y intéressez un petit peu non
non non vous en foutez qua non je pense
ou pas mais de lyncher intéressé
s'intéressait déjà pas la politique il
ya 30 ans était encore pas du tout
maintenant
ben oui oui vous avez choisi la corse
par paresse c'est pour la beauté tout
s'est vraiment et bien sûr une belle
phrase son travail vous dites ça paye
dans le futur le travailleur de la
paresse ça paye comptant
alors vous vivez là vous avez la
retraite de la sacem ne savais pas ça
verser une retraite la sacem bien suis
retraité et à la retraite alors vous
dites je suis ni riche ni bien portants
on vous croit malade toujours non c'est
vrai vous savez donc mort des gens moins
dix fois moi comme une forme à
plaisanterie que jacques dutronc est
mort vous je suis content de vous voir
c'est pour ça que j'ai dix ans nous
faudra mettre sur ma tombe encore encore
non mais c'est vrai tous les journaux
toutes les télés en votre micro prête
pourtant vous buvez plus là si j'ai rien
là je comprends pas pourtant j'ai
demandé qui veut quoi j'ai demandé c'est
parti vous dites je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai arrêté de babar pardon le jour où
j'ai arrêté de boire je vais te bourrer
voilà voilà voilà
mais non il n'a pas arrêté de 6 et une
analyse d'urines saint jacques dutronc